my question is for you and Michael you
guys sort of alluded to it already but
um there's sort of rumors that there may
be another movie so I'm just wondering
what the chances are that the Ripley and
Hicks will be the kick-ass couple that
they deserve today
such a nice way to put it thank you um
yes there is an incredible script and
written and to be directed by Neill
Blomkamp who was a fan growing up in
South Africa who loved these movies so
much that he broke the tapes and when we
were working together on chappie a movie
I loved he we started chatting about how
the series left Ripley and I had not
wanted to do a fifth one I just I didn't
want to go to earth I thought going to
earth was like a little boring so um
anyway we that whole first day we
started just talking about it and four
months later I got a script that was so
amazing and gives the fans everything
they are looking for plus innovates in a
lot of ways with things that just
immediately for me became part of the
world so he has work to do all I have
worked to do and I'm hoping when we
finished those jobs will circle back and
start to do it so thanks for asking
you